Jupiter ascending is directed by the
Wachowski z-- and stars Channing Tatum
Mila Kunis Eddie Redmayne and Sean Bean
and is marketed as a sci-fi adventure
tale that spans the galaxies about a
woman named Jupiter played by Mila Kunis
who's being hunted by this alien race
when reality the film is actually about
an intergalactic squabble over land I've
been a humongous fan of the Wachowski
since the first matrix from the first
matrix film is one of my all-time
favorite movies it inspired me so much
as a kid and it continues to inspire me
to this day now I went into this movie
skeptical but excited because the
Wachowski czar at least always able to
deliver a very interesting and appealing
visual experience and one of the opening
action scenes in this movie is so
mind-blowing is so white-knuckle grip my
seats get excited sweaty palms I was
like wow this movie is going to be
incredible it's this awesome aerial
battle through this city it looks
amazing and Michael Giacchino's score is
fantastic I adored his score I can't
wait to pick it up it was so well done
the special effects are awesome but
there are times where it feels very fake
and you recognize you're just looking at
an entirely 100% CGI image and there are
times when that feels very off-putting
especially with the green-screen now
this is something that sometimes 3d
films actually struggle with is the fact
that when you are separating a human
being from the background and you know
that background is green-screen it makes
it look more like green-screen
I like Channing Tatum in this movie I
really like the idea of his hover boots
and how he was able to basically skate
across the air that was a fantastic idea
and very original and Sean Bean was also
awesome in this movie I loved his
character he was a lot of fun and
nothing else
Jupiter ascending is kind of terrible
here's the deal with Jupiter ascending
guys it starts off kind of strong you
kind of into it and then all of a sudden
it turns into a two-hour series of
people squabbling over who owns the
earth Emil akunis plays this character
who's a fish out of water she's suddenly
around all these amazing things in space
and she's surprised but all she ever
says is holy crap that's the highest
level of emotion we really get out of
her character and eventually she
dissolves
to a very weak woman in a series of
scenes in which she's either about to
sign her life away or sign her
inheritance away and Channing Tatum has
to come in and save her the movie
divulges into an endless string of him
having to come and save her when she
thinks he's gone and she's about to give
away her whole life or something seem to
seem to scene that's what keeps
happening because she's a weak woman who
can't take care of herself of course
come on which house keys you can write a
better script than that make her a
stronger character it was really
disappointing some of the romantic
dialogue is so horrific aliy horrendous
that there were people throughout my
theater laughing when you're not
supposed to and I'm talking multiple
people and at one point the entire
audience had this cringe-worthy
uncomfortable laugh where she said
something I'm supposed to be romantic
and it was just Twilight and there's one
thing I haven't mentioned yet and I
really should and that's Eddie Redmayne
look this man's a talented actor very
talented but oh my gosh whatever he was
doing this movie didn't work
he's like hello I'm a villain and all of
a sudden I'll explode his performance
was truly bad and it just did not work
at all whatever he was being told or
whatever he was thinking he was doing it
was not right after that incredibly
breathtaking action scene in the first
act the movie divulges into this long
series of very boring conversations with
strange alien creatures with ugly awful
terrible character design and these
moments with these creatures really take
you out of the scene because it'll be
like this super serious scene
everything's on the line it's super
dramatic you're supposed to be into this
moment it's incredible you're feeling it
you're feeling you're getting excited
you're supposed to be anyway the captain
goes like full speed ahead and it pans
down to the pilot and it's this strange
Elephant Man who goes how am I supposed
to not laugh at that Jupiter ascending
is a movie that could have been so much
more
unfortunately my best way to describe
this movie is the Phantom Menace you
went into the Phantom Menace the opening
action scene you're like okay this is
pretty fun but their dialogues kind of I
don't know about that and then the
podrace like yeah that's pretty cool but
the dialogue and then the Darth Maul
lightsaber fight was amazing and oh my
gosh but the dialogue and there's all
these random scenes throughout the
middle of trade negotiations and
political discussions in which people
babble on
things you don't understand or care
about it's as if Jupiter ascending
requires you to read a whole bunch of
expanded universe novels before you can
actually appreciate this film I'm going
to give Jupiter ascending
a d-plus guys what are your thoughts on
Jupiter ascending let me know below
thank you so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck Benoist